my latest annual leads and on this video
I'm gonna be showing you exactly how you
can find properties 20% below market
value and more every single day now
previously in the past I've talked about
how return on investment is the thing
you really should be looking for don't
worry about whether it's below market
value now I've changed very slightly
because right now in 2018 there's so
much opportunity to find deals 20% below
market value so I say if you can get
both 20% below market value and a
minimum of 20% return on investment that
is really where the money is at and also
it's very easy to find properties that
are 20% below market value so here is
how you do it step 1
the properties that you're gonna be
looking for below market value
you also want them to be getting a high
return properties that give you a high
return typically our properties that you
buy low reason is if you've got a house
that's five hundred thousand pounds the
rent is not that much more than a
property that's a hundred thousand
pounds the correlation is not quite
there so you're gonna be looking for
properties that quite cheap so you're
going to go to right move right now
you've got to do this because the
results will just astonish you go to
right move and you're gonna search in an
area north of Birmingham for properties
priced between 50 and let's say 70
thousand pounds so fifty to seventy
thousand pounds you'll search 40 mile
radius and you'll find there are
thousands and thousands of these
properties now rather than searching
from the lowest or highest price on
right if you're gonna search from oldest
listed oldest listed means that probably
quite motivated look at the properties
and you can very easily value a property
by looking at what others sold for in
the street and get an idea so so check
that the asking price is also the same
as the market value once you've done
that you can I then ring up the estate
agent this is the scary bit the oh my
gosh I've actually got a cool agent yes
in order to make money in order to get
results you need to do a little bit of
work I'm gonna call the agent
I'm gonna give you the words exactly
that you must say when you call the
agent so first thing you gonna say is
that you're saying hi agent I'm ringing
about the property on Church Road for
50,000 pounds do you know the one now
the reasoning that's ad no the one is
because what amateur investors do they
start spouting off about all the night
that's offering on one of it and the
person they're talking to could be the
mortgage broker who happen to just pick
up the phone so thirty-two Church Road
some fifty thousand pounds do you know
the one yeah another one how can I help
great then you're gonna say and here
these are the magic words okay so it's
on for fifty thousand pounds you're
gonna say okay no look I don't want to
offend anybody but I can probably only
afford to pay for the house about forty
thousand pounds
although that's 20 percent below market
value about forty thousand pounds
I don't offend anybody so is it worth me
making a viewing or not then at that
point if they say yeah it is worth you
making a viewing they can't and moan at
you when you put offering a 20% below
market value in fact if they say yes it
is worth you making your viewing there's
a very good chance that the estate agent
knows that the vendor will take that
offer you spend a day doing that and
then book a day of viewings where you're
looking like ten houses which have all
been pre-qualified BMV offer 20% below
market value on all of them unless they
have ten you get five you just bought
five properties 20% below market value
what do you then do with those houses or
you can buy them and maybe I don't know
refinance and potentially potentially or
you can pass them on to an investor for
a fee make sure you're compliant if
you're going to do that but but that's
how you can find below market ideals so
best-case when you bring up is the
serega she's one of my students come on
storage you come and sit down second
we're gonna roleplay this one you can
see exactly how this looks bother my
serger how old are you I'm 25 years old
and you're an Academy member and you
she's smashing in the moment how many
deals have you doing the last month to
property deals in the last two months
no that's month and when you were at the
deal finding extravaganza we did this
exercise right yes and there was lots of
deals being found this way at least five
at least five I think he was more than
that with a point five minutes so this
really works so this is the best case
scenario okay so hi I'm thinking about
Church Street it's on for 60,000 pounds
do you know the one oh yeah yeah I'm
working on that myself
right oh sweet oh yeah it's one for
sixty thousand now I'm gonna work out
what 20 percent below 60 is which would
be $12,000 yeah okay it's on for 60,000
um listen I don't want to offend anybody
but I'd likely to be only able to offer
around about 48,000 pounds for the house
I know that's I know that's below the
market value but is it worth me booking
a viewing or not yeah absolutely awesome
okay I've got a day on Tuesday where I'm
gonna be doing some viewings is it
available to view on Tuesday yeah
absolutely
bingo now how often does that happen
okay I say 1 in 10 you must be extra
good on the phone you are good so 1 in
10 they're gonna say that and there's a
very fair chance that they'll then
accept your your 20% be in the offer now
this is the worst case that can happen
quickly Highland I'm ringing about 20
church streets on for 6,000 pounds yeah
do you know the one yes awesome
listen um I don't know offend anybody
but I'd likely to only be able to offer
48 thousand pounds is it worth me
booking of ok no problem thanks no
worries I'm only any broker or poor
because of that am I am i any weaker
because of that now no no that's the
worst that can happen
in fact of what you do which is really
cool what did you say when they say no
um I just thanked them for their time
and I'm really honest with them and I
just say look
this is a situation I mean I'm actually
an investor I'm looking for sort of
houses that you've got sellers that I'm
really looking to get rid of if for
whatever reason they might want to leave
the country they might not want the
house do you have any on your books that
you know whatever the asking prices the
owners are gonna say yes to a below
market value deal boom I've had yeses
from estate agents saying that and I've
had one estate agent in particular
emailing me a list straight afterwards
saying it's I've seen them and also just
saying that she's gonna go for all the
books and you know to sort of stop
saying that and you really yeah because
if we don't ask you don't get right so
that's great also the thing that you
should not do is just book a load of
viewings and then put in loads of beyond
the office because then you can offend
people lose friends yes but if you do
that first it takes like 20 seconds on
phone then you get a bunch of
pre-qualified properties to view and
then offer on that is a genius way to
get properties below market value
yeah my first Rieger boom hope to see
you very soon
[Music]
you